Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Doritos in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Doritos come
in four portion sizes,
starting with this one,
which is a 30-gram bag.
However, these only come
in the form of multipacks,
either as a multipack of five
or as a multipack of 12.
The smallest bag of Doritos
you can get in the US
is the multipack size,
which is this, 1 ounce.
You can get these in multipacks of 10.
Next up we have a grab
bag, which is 48 grams.
These are usually found as part of
a lunchtime meal deal, just as a snack.
Next size up, a 1 3/4 size bag.
Next size up, this is
the 2 3/4 pounds bag.
Next up we have our regular bag,
which in the UK is 180 grams.
That's nothing.
Our standard bag size, 9.75 ounces.
Finally, we have our biggest size,
which is a share-size bag
coming in at 230 grams.
We got you beat again, UK.
This is our party pack, 14.5 ounces,
which is also 411 grams.
88% larger than any
size you have in the UK.
Let's count out all the Doritos
in our respective largest bags
to see what the difference looks like.
The good news is that I'm
counting out this bag,
which is 230 grams.
Joe is counting out a
party-sized bag of American ones,
which is 425 grams,
so he might be here a while.
Sorry, Joe.
Yeah, thanks, Harry.
[sighs]
Joe: We're doing the math so
all you stoners don't have to.
15 times 8.
11 times 10, plus 1, 2, 3.
Count out, like, 10 chips, weigh them,
divide by 10, and then go, OK,
that's how much a chip on average weighs,
and then weigh the pile of crumbs
and divide it by that number,
seeing how many chips are –
does that make sense?
I'm gonna be here all day.
So, one chip weighs 2.5 grams.
So the remainder of the crumbs,
65 grams.
What's 65 divided by 2.5?
So, altogether, 168 chips.
Wow, we're really smart.
That was smart what we
just did there, right?
Nine.
Leaving our total at 119 Doritos.
My flatmates can eat these.
I won't tell them the amount
of fondling that's gone on.
Here's everything that's
in a Cool Original Dorito
in the UK.
Corn (maize), vegetable oils
(sunflower and rapeseed
in various proportions),
[Harry talking over himself]
And here's everything in a
Cool Ranch Dorito in the US.
All right.
Corn; vegetable oil,
which is corn, canola,
and/or sunflower oil;
maltodextrin (made from corn).
A lot of corn in these chips.
[Joe talking over himself]
There are a few things
to watch out for in here
as well as in other Dorito flavors.
Ah, good old USA-only food coloring,
Red 40 and Yellow No. 5.
It's in everything these days.
And the UK, of course,
opts to color its Doritos
with things like annatto and paprika.
A fun one to know is that
the Doritos in the UK
and the US both contain
potassium chloride.
Now, in normal doses,
this is perfectly normal
and safe to eat in food,
as it's used to reduce the
sodium content in salt.
However, it's also one
of the three drugs used
in a three-drug cocktail of chemicals
used for lethal injections.
Enough potassium chloride will increase
your blood's concentration of potassium,
which will create an irregular heartbeat
and lead to cardiac arrest.
Ah, how many Doritos would
it take to kill someone?
I think just one, if you crush it up,
put in a syringe, and just
jam it right into the arm.
Death by Cool Ranch.
That's how I want to go.
I've eaten five of these,
and I feel like I'm gonna die.
This here is 100 grams
of Cool Ranch Doritos.
And in the US, that contains 535 calories.
The total fat is 28.56 grams,
sodium 678.3 milligrams. Oof.
That's a lot of sodium
in that pile right there.
We actually call those
Cool Original over here
because no one in the
UK knows what ranch is.
But as far as we're
aware, they are the same.
In the UK, 100 grams of
Cool Original Doritos
contains 498 calories,
25.5 grams of fat,
592 milligrams of sodium,
and 58.1 grams of carbs.
So our version has slightly more calories,
fat, and sodium than the UK version.
What about the least healthy flavor?
Well, in the UK, Flame Grilled Steak
is the highest in calories and sodium.
Four Flame Grilled Steak grab bags
would be your entire daily allowance
of fat, sodium, and calories.
"With intense flavours, full-on crunch,
and a Grilled Steak Kick,
Doritos are the great tasting
bold snack for when you're
getting together with mates!"
Bold of you to assume I'm
sharing these with my friends.
What about the least healthiest Dorito?
Well, the calorie count
is pretty much similar
among all of them, but if
you're paying attention
to your sodium intake,
which I guess you should be,
then I would say steer clear of
the Spicy Sweet Chili Doritos.
100 grams of these,
so roughly two of these,
is 963.9 milligrams of sodium.
That is a 42% increase
from the Cool Ranch.
[crunching]
Everything tastes like insanity.
I don't mind this, but you gotta, like,
water them down or something, Doritos.
This is way too strong.
Yet, I'm eating them.
Here are all the Doritos
you'll find in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
And here are most of the Doritos
that are native to the US.
Let's start with the classics.
In the UK, you will find Guacamole flavor,
Flame Grilled Steak flavor,
Lightly Salted, and Hint of Lime Doritos.
Then we have a few
which aren't technically
exclusives but have some differences,
which I thought were worth pointing out.
For example, as I previously mentioned,
we call these ones Cool
Original instead of Cool Ranch,
because ranch just really isn't
a popular condiment in the UK.
There are also a couple of
color differences worth noting.
For example, the red ones in the UK
are actually Chilli Heatwave,
whereas the bright orange
ones are Tangy Cheese.
In the UK, Doritos also
offers a range of salsas
and other dips, like nacho
cheese and sour cream.
In the UK, you are actively
encouraged by Doritos,
and society as a whole,
to dip your Doritos into these sauces,
as you can see on the packaging here.
But apparently Americans
find that super weird
and will only ever dip
plain chips into salsa.
Is that right, Joe?
Doritos and dips seems like flavor mayhem.
The thought of dipping
Nacho Cheese Doritos
into nacho cheese,
I think one bite would just
unplug you from the matrix.
That seems, like, impossible to handle.
But, yeah, go for it.
Sweaty hands. Sweaty Dorito hands.
Save my pride.
That's really on there.
I have no grip strength.
Oh, wow.
Before, you know, I've
loosened it up for you.
There we go.
Nice.
Every episode.
I need to work on my grip
strength, go climbing.
To me, it's just like that
scene in "Ratatouille"
where Remy is feeding his
brother a piece of cheese
and a piece of strawberry,
and if you eat them one at
a time, they're pretty good.
But if you mix them together ...
[dynamic music]
It's a taste explosion.
Delicious! Why wouldn't you do this?
You guys are missing out, OK?
You're missing out.
I don't think I'm missing
out. I think that seems like
way more flavor than I
can handle, personally.
Enjoy!
So, they got the Tapatio flavored Dorito.
Collab, love to see it.
This guy's Salsa Verde.
Spicy Nacho.
Spicy Sweet Chili, we saw
that a little bit earlier.
This one, the Flamas!
Just look at the fire on
that. These gotta be hot.
Whoa.
Uh-oh, I don't like the look of this chip.
Yeah, yeah.
I would say that the Flamas flavor
reminds me a lot of Takis.
But if that's not Taki enough for you –
and this, I think, is
actually really irritating –
Doritos also has something
called the Dinamitas.
What do those look like?
Takis.
Doritos, come on, guys.
Let another company make some money.
Takis are better.
Two other US exclusives that
I could not get my hands on
by the filming of this episode
is Blazin' Buffalo & Ranch
and Poppin' Jalapeno.
What appears to be, I don't know,
an attempt at making a healthier Dorito,
if there's such a thing.
So, White Cheddar and Spicy White Cheddar.
"At Simply, our snacks
are made with ingredients
you can feel good about and
come from the brands you love.
We call it PURE DELICIOUSNESS."
Barf!
Ingredients: organic corn,
organic expeller-pressed sunflower oil,
organic cheddar cheese,
milk, cheese culture solids,
enzymes, organic maltodextrin.
They just put the word organic
in front of everything.
Organic maltodextrin
made from corn, sea salt,
organic butter, cream,
salt, organic skim milk,
organic spices, citric
acid, organic garlic powder.
So I think these are
more organic. [laughs]
You know what they taste like? Sunchips.
I hate Sunchips.
We also have an exclusive Dorito shape,
which is Doritos Stax.
These are kind of like
a Dorito-Pringle hybrid,
which are mostly just
like regular Doritos,
but then stacked in a triangular tube.
Yo!
Doritos is going after Takis,
now they're going after Pringles?
Doritos, let someone else
make a dollar in this space!
These come in four flavors,
and we've got them all here.
We've got a Mexican Chilli Salsa Stax,
these Flaming Chicken Wings Stax,
some Sour Cream & Onion Stax,
and Ultimate Cheese Stax.
Yeah, I mean, they kind of look like
maybe thinner than normal Doritos.
I wonder why these are Ultimate Cheese
compared to just our normal Tangy Cheese.
Let's find out.
Those aren't bad.
They're pretty good, they're pretty good.
That is an exclusive container shape,
but in the US, we have
an exclusive chip shape.
And that is these, the 3D Crunch.
Two flavors that we got are Spicy Ranch.
Spicy Ranch?
I think I'm in trouble.
And Chili Cheese Nacho.
I like it. They're,
like, lighter, fluffier.
Let me ask you guys a question.
What shape does that look like?
Think really hard.
Announcer: Live from New
York, it's "What Shape Is It?"
What does this shape look like?
Imagine if it didn't
close up at the bottom.
This looks exactly like a Bugle!
Doritos is going after everyone.
That's why I like them so
much, they taste like Bugles.
Stay out of Bugles' lane, Doritos.
You got a lot to learn.
You got a lot to learn about Bugles.
And you got a lot to learn about Takis.
Actually, these guys are
kind of growing on me.
Overall though, yeah.
I like Doritos.